if you live in a city then you trade in
that city you buy perhaps breakfast or a
newspaper or something more exciting you
sell as well probably your time to an
employer you may well have come to your
city precisely because you could sell
your time at a higher price in this
section we're going to explore how
cities make markets and how markets make
cities and hopefully you will come to
understand your city a little bit better
cities typically have a wider range of
services scale makes that possible
meaning that there are more types of
restaurants more rare Goods and more
specialized services like nail salons or
bespoke tailors or fortune tellers
internet retailing has leveled the
playing field between city and town for
many products but not for services that
require face-to-face contact not for
restaurants and not for higher-end
products that you want to see before you
buy like diamonds cities unable labor
markets to work more efficiently you can
hop from job to job more easily in a big
metropolitan area you can weather a mass
layoff more readily in a city and that
helps explain why joblessness is lower
in metropolitan America if you run a
business you will find it easier to find
the labor you need in a large
metropolitan area the success of cities
often depends on how they do as markets
when labor markets break down as they
did in Detroit after the faltering of
the Big Three automakers the city itself
spiraled into decline the collapse of
retail on Main streets in the US and
high streets in the UK has often left a
great emptiness in the heart of the city
internet-based markets like uber and
lyft enter into urban areas and they
take advantage of urban scale yet they
also upset regulators who often try to
protect incumbents from competition
understanding the interplay between
cities and trade is helpful if you want
to understand how to get the most out of
your city or if you want to make a guess
about what its future will be or if you
just want to sensibly discuss policies
that impact trade like the regulation of
uber or food trucks hopefully these
videos will help you to better
understand the past and future of
commercial cities
you